mr. knee gel thanks coming on hey thank
you doctor so I want to ask with this
but first I have to ask about a piece of
breaking news or catherine herridge just
has out saying that in January of this
year January 10th Deputy Attorney
General Rosen Stein went up to the hill
met with Republican members of the House
in tell me how did this be with them and
threatened them with the subpoena of
their emails and phone records this is
what one of them said I read it as it
not-so-veiled threat to unleash the full
prosecutorial power of the State against
as DOJ on background has confirmed that
something like that did happen what is
what is that about
well I don't know that they've confirmed
that exactly in fact the FBI director
the senior ethics attorney for the
Department of Justice who was in the
room say that's a mischaracterization
really of what occurred and it also I
think indicates that there's been a
breakdown of relationships when in fact
since January great deal of progress has
been made we understand in this
department that we are accountable to
the president we are accountable to
Congress and we need to be cooperative
with them to produce as many documents
as rationally and legally and properly
as can be produced to produce them and
we've made tremendous progress in that
regard really did did the attempt ADEA
Deputy Attorney General threatened to
subpoena the email or phone records of
members of the House in subcommittee
well I was not in the room and I can't
speak to what occurred all I can say is
that the people at the Chris ray the
director of the FBI and our senior
ethics attorney was there and others and
did not see it in that same fashion okay
so as a factual matter you don't think
that that happened I'm confident that
deputy Rosen Stein 28 years in the
Department of Justice did not improperly
threaten anyone on that occasion but we
do believe that we have tried to be
cooperative with them and made progress
in the in months as as the months have
gone by
and in fact I've had some good
relationships with top members of
Congress okay so you have made news
recently by undoing an Obama error rule
about asylum seekers give us the
overview would think most Americans like
the idea that this would be a haven for
people suffering around the world
lots of people claim asylum what do we
know about the veracity of their claims
that's a good question
seven years ago 5,000 people were
applied for asylum on claiming a
credible fear of being at home in their
home country and they needed to flee
that country that number jumped to 94
thousand in just seven years it's
overwhelming our system over 80% of
those claims of being denied by the
immigration judges as being are not
meritorious so it is a big problem for
us but it's it's each one of those is
requiring trials and factual decisions
by our judges we're gonna add a hundred
judges and that may not yet be enough
judges to handle the cases we need to
give the judges better guidance they
need to go back to the fundamental
principles and laws and rules of the
immigration and nationalization Act and
if we do that then we're in a position
where some of these cases can be
promptly decided you do not get to come
to America if you have a private threat
or a someone personally attacks you you
do not get to have asylum for that it's
based on your race your religion your
nationality that you're part of some
special identifiable group that's being
persecuted in your home country that's
what it takes to have an asylum and we
need to get this straight and I think it
will help us the decision I made I
believe it's right legally I'm totally
confident it's consistent with the
intent of the drafters of the ia our law
and I believe it will help us manage our
caseloads better and give more focus to
the people who deserve to be given
asylum
and help us eliminate those that are not
worthy of this asylum with over 80% of
the applications are fraudulent there's
obviously a problem so the DOJ has also
recently weighed in on the question of
speech on campus what can the federal
government do the Department of Justice
do to ensure that people's First
Amendment rights are protected and why
is it wise to take until 2018 to get DOJ
involved in this it's one of the big
challenges of our time I have come to
believe and it's almost unbelievable
that major colleges and universities
would be taking action that restrict the
right of free speech on a college campus
it's just got to be confronted we have
the authority under law to file a
statement of interest in a ongoing
litigation so cases are being filed
against the universities by students who
complain and if we think their
complaints are meritorious then we can
file a statement of interest joining
with them and explaining why we at the
Department of Justice think thinks these
concerns are real and justified in a
court relief is appropriate so we've had
some success we've had two cases where
there's been a major change in the
college and universities actions and two
cases where the judge has dismissed the
or failure of rejected a motion to
dismiss these cases by the universities
and align the trials to go forward we
think it's a very important thing
students should be participating in
robust debate they are not to be
intimidated they ought not to be driven
by political correctness to where you
can't even speak up in class class or on
campus it's just immediate what an
upside-down world it is when a
conservative Attorney General is
defending the First Amendment against
liberals it's like things have changed
almost too much but Attorney General
thank you I appreciate it thank you good
to be with you